hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to dead-end Road
now I found this horror game and it
looked very interesting because it was
kind of a pseudo pixelated style I have
no idea how it's gonna play I have no
idea how it's gonna hello grandma how
are you doing oh so you finally arrived
my dear Oh have I you can come closer if
you'd like I would not like that
I'd like to maintain as much distance
between me and that fucked-up face as I
possibly can
holy [ __ ] perhaps my appearance
frightens you you're goddamn right it
does what happened to your eyes ah there
is no need to be afraid child you seek
instructions on the ritual yes okay you
know you said there's no need to be
afraid and then you say things like
there's gonna be rituals and I need
instructions for them I'm not okay with
this this is absolutely absurd that is
what my visitors usually ask of me okay
it is true that the ritual has power the
power to grant one wish but it comes at
a terrible cost okay what I can see you
will not be dissuaded can you I'm easily
dissuaded you're gonna tell me to leave
and I'll go go perform the ritual then
return to me and bring with you the
following a book a bell and a candle
okay
a book a bell and a candle can you
remember that my dear yeah a book a bell
in the candle no no I need these things
well I'll go get him for you grab off so
then do you still wish to proceed very
well then we shall begin with a book a
bell in a candle oh geez oh geez oh geez
perform the ritual with the directional
input I don't know what I'm doing it
what do we huh whoa did I do it
do I get my wish now whoa okay
ah this is bizarre okay oh okay I get it
it glows where it's supposed to be and
each of the button controls a different
okay that's supposed to be there
those two are supposed to be there and
this is supposed to be here
ah there we go okay got it got it got it
look about on the candle did I get those
or did I need to get those what is your
request of the dark powers um how do I
suddenly wish were a bigger dick
uh a huge massive in oh uh okay Oh
Theresa um
ultimate power a dog oh uh a dog Oh
named Fred a [ __ ] ultimate power
hell [ __ ] give it to me what's the
terrible Casso hey whoa
Oh with you I should have had my defense
up
hey hey what did I do
do I have ultimate power no no no what I
did no no what I did bro okay alrighty
then
I'm driving in a car now oh geez
I love the styling of this game by the
way I know it's like it's low res but
it's intentionally low res oh jeez
Oh all cheese or cheese oh jeez oh cool
jeez I'm outta here baby I don't know
where I'm going but who Hey
oh this wind that brushes through these
hills oh boy whoa boy whoa boy hello
okay goodbye gonna crash blow jeez but I
don't know supposed to be doing with
this where are we going
I'm so confused and panicked open the
grandma doesn't show up at any moment
she never hobbies what did I hit she
never even told me what the terrible
price actually was okay whoa I see that
the the meter it's counting down so I
should be getting whoa hey Trash Can
that box is okay oh [ __ ]
oh geez oh geez oh geez I'm all over the
road ow [ __ ] backing up
yep yep yep yep yep okay let's try that
again without dying hopefully anyway not
ever since you're on this whoo
goddamn woohoo I didn't know this is
gonna be skill-based I don't have a lot
of skills so I don't know how it's gonna
work out
Jesus well I shouldn't be going
full-throttle
oh god god damn it I didn't do ha
yeah I'm getting close I'm only 1.5
units away from my destination I think I
don't know what that sign said but it
was probably important for me to know it
okay Ruud got straight
okay almost there okay I did it
Abbeville turn alot okay
I'm going to Abbeville the following
shops appear to still be open
supermarket mechanic pharmacy pawnshop
leave oh thank God some places are still
open at this hour why do I need money
what what what am i doing I am so
confused
hi whoa what happened to your eyes oh
geez
following items are available those
Gizem I don't like the way this guy is
staring at me let's get some cigs and
get out of here yeah it's get dad my
cigarettes
get some chocolate don't judge me I'm
emotional at the moment I just summoned
a demon and got him in power so don't
you mess with me bro okay I got stuff
scratchcard I guess no sir okay okay I'm
not a winner this time I'll give it one
more go and then we'll see what happens
whoa bingo yeah winner is me this is the
ultimate power finally getting to me all
right I'm out of here all right I guess
I could go to the mechanic Jesus what is
happening here oh god I don't like this
guy's attitude I don't like any of these
guys his face yeah right so I guess I
could repair the car but I don't know
why whoa okay can I oh geez repair it
all right did that it's good I guess buy
fuel you okay upgrades
what is this bull bars reduce collision
damage what the [ __ ] this one alright
okay that's what I can do this this
bizarre this just bizarre I don't even
know why this is happening is so weird
hello I can feel this guy silently
judging me
let's see quaaludes why is that on here
I'm out of here
hey God yeah very pawnshop hey buddy
following items are available Bible
matches collar Bell Oh a book a candle
and a bell don't I need a bell wait do I
still need these things I don't know if
I need these things I need a candle I I
guess I need this wood jeez this isn't a
candle though well I got matches for a
candle I suppose there's something I
don't like about this place well it
seems like a normal supermarket than a
pound sham all right whatever
I guess I'm gonna head back now
okay where whoa what the Wyatt oh [ __ ]
this is going back I don't know I don't
know where I'm going I don't know what
I'm doing
what the hell is going on here oh geez
dude orgies scoobo whoa homeless he dead
hello what was that
oh there's cows on the road
I am unbelievably confused incredibly
confused hey Roseanne David dubbin do it
do what do what oh [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey why
is this happening why is this happening
whoa okay uh oh geez the road is getting
awfully treasures hey whoa what was that
what you suffered a fatal car accident
to restart I don't even know what
happened it wasn't fatal what are you
talking about oh god damn it
what the [ __ ] what happened why did I
not get to it what the [ __ ] happened
what eternal life so I don't die the
dark powers have not understood your
requests
what giant P nor Jess beauty beauty
give me beauty I'm not moving
you are beyond the something of God here
the reach maybe I have no idea okay so
now I'm assuming I need a book a bell on
a candle to be able to get what I need
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what are
you dumping dude what are you dumping
stop that what did you just hit me with
whoo ah what is that ah was that meat
why was there meat where is that thing
through oh whoa whoa okay Jesus
this road is a lot more treacherous than
the first one I went on oh crap oh crap
oh hey whoa hi goodbye holy [ __ ] what
was that
why are you there house weird okay
the [ __ ] happened here why am I in a
tube of meat oh geez
I'd probably be bad if I was driving
down Highway and not able to know where
I was going but thankfully God why is
all the [ __ ] happening now because
beauty is a much more Paul she's
beauties a much more difficult request
to answer can I come can I back up
please please oh jeez okay I think we
reached the straightaway finally which
is awfully nice uh jeez what the hell is
going on here I having a god damn clue
but I need a bucket Bell and a candle a
book a bell and a candle would be lovely
a book of melon a candle huh a Verve
away verbal okay supermarket maybe I can
try it with a scratch card again well
okay that was a waste of money
all right I'm out of here no not that
jeez cowbell a math textbook that's a
book that is definitely a book and a
candle but fire lighter isn't exactly
what I needed but just in case I'm gonna
get it case I need to light the candle
all right so I got a bail baby I'll be
the bin to be all right I'm gonna save
my money until I get to the next place
okay so drought Shire or North Hallows I
imagine drought shires where I just came
from considering I turned left into this
place but I'm gonna go left here to try
to go a ways away I'm gonna go at a very
reasonable speed Oh way whoa see that's
why why are these guys driving on random
sides of the road seem very oh we got a
body
why is there a body in the middle of the
street that didn't make it ago
whoo hello
I will be down there with you is that
what you're saying well who Hey
I think actually I just realized
everything's in pound so I think driving
on the left side of the road is the only
appropriate way to do things I can't see
please turn it on okay whoa jeez okay
well I didn't seem dirty I'm glad that
my problems are affecting the rest of
the world and I can't see a goddamn
thing oh oh is that the guy throwing
meat again
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay now we're getting the heart of the
matter that cheese in the butt Oh God
jeez holy crap can I turn my lights back
on please oh geez I can control that
hi whoa whoa whoa
eyeballs that's weird okay now I'm
getting it okay oh hey hey tiger No ah
sorry poor God I'm sorry I'm sorry okay
my sanity is not doing well
all right whoa holy [ __ ] I'm okay what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I just wanted me
whoo whoo whoo watch out buddy oh [ __ ]
no no you said man okay
[ __ ] hey good
a bird oh well that bird had a bad day
looks like I bet I'm having a bad day
with my car I'll being beat to [ __ ] no
you do not not throw any more meat at me
well what is that Bo's that huh oh geez
well the hankered how do I fix that okay
never mind it fixed itself
don't don't though hey what the hell's
happening Rome I'd appreciate you bein
in my backseat [ __ ] okay I think I
finally made it to the straightaway I
shouldn't got it I shouldn't got it just
in case yes
Oh interior lights okay okay
well what the [ __ ]
I think I turned on the radio ah okay
dead-end road I started there went to
amiable okay
oh so I need to go am I trying to go to
dead-end road I think I am so if I just
keep taking left's out of here I should
be able to get everything I need and get
it the dead-end road I think that's my
objective here
okay okay
supermarket I just need a candle damn it
okay after you dark alley search alley
during the search of the alley the only
items of interest you find are discarded
needles and a rat knowing on a rotten
morsel the resembles a human toe you
decided to skim to to your investigation
of the alley okay alright then I wish I
hadn't gone this way me too me too buddy
it's your buddy
maybe the antique store has something
grimoire lighter broken Bell a grimoire
of what Klaatu Barada nikto that seems
important I'll get that and then I'll
hold out for the candle I'm pretty sure
I don't have that all right just keep
driving just keep driving it's all we
can hope for I just can't hit anything
else because I think my car is in bad
shape
we're going left we're just gonna make
left's we're gonna be cool
a bird okay okay
come to Daddy come to Daddy
no thank you I'm perfectly okay where I
am
oh boy that's head hello head Luigi's
will almost hit that hole again half
done okay
I don't know what happened whoa whoa
whoa
Mookie birdies
okay all right
oh geez you know I think I think the way
the game is programmed it's not actually
uh it's not actually whoo it's not
actually uh any turns that are on the
road it's not actually any turns that
are on the road the road just randomly
shifts left and right at random
intervals I think that's the way it's
programmed oh geez
doing fine oh geez
and this is a hard road to drive on whoa
okay now it's potty mmm
Mel's tasty buddy whoa hey buddy Mooji
oh oh oh oh oh that's not good
oh that's not good oh whoa
do clothes can't see a goddamn thing
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry oh that ain't
good my car is about to explode
I don't think I'm gonna make it I don't
think I'm gonna make it
whoa boy dead good I'm driving the
middle of the road or at least try oh I
think I might have made it final stretch
god I don't think I have enough money to
repair my car at this point my whole rig
should have blown all my money on
scratch um's alright let's try the pawn
shop see if there's camper votive candle
that's what I needed
really nice candle thank you okay so
that's good
let's see if I can actually repair
enough to do any damage but I don't know
all right let's see repair not enough I
need all cash I can't just do a partial
repair god damn it that's gonna be a
[ __ ] well I can't do anything I don't
even think I can buy scratchings it'll
be good enough I think I'm just [ __ ]
well might as well try doodly doodly
doodly doodly dang okay might as well
try again there's no risk in it cuz
otherwise I don't even think I'll have
enough to do anything nope not a winner
I know I'm unlucky
is this a bad run
okay so no no winners that time but
we're fine
don't need to buy anything else but I
got all the supplies so if I can just
make it through I think just one more
town I'm not sure but who knows who
knows I'm probably not gonna make it not
gonna make it
now get a bigot can't make it won't make
it can't do it no ain't gonna happen
yeah alright if I can saw my map I'm
currently in whole Rick so it's
literally just one more go until I get
to dead-end road which I imagine is
where I need to go and I've been very
conservative about fuel no what let's
try it what's the harm
we're gonna happen dead-end road let's
do this I'm gonna go inch snail pace
whoa geez whoa geez this road seems
weird but bad smell bass you can't be me
now you could probably be me
oh geez
whoa that Danone what with the fire and
such
Dante me well okay uh hi friend my
friend
oh geez oh geez did I avoid that okay I
think I did [ __ ] bird [ __ ] damn it
oh geez Road friggin curving at random
whoa what the hell what is this morning
a fatal error has occurred what are you
talking about
system has no chance to recover what are
you talking about you sure there's no
dead
okay is that supposed to be my computer
I think I'm a little more advanced than
dass oh that's that's that's very bad
that's that's right that's probably bad
that's right bad bottle low other car
who would be trotting on this road who
just who would be who would who it
tolerate this road oh geez I'm not even
gonna try to pass this guy
he seems to be more capable navigator
than I am listen to the lovely sounds of
this radio station
down past them
which is there we go hope you got
the slip dick and impossible luck
Oh g-god god dammit [ __ ] that
whoa
I've met a terrible fate haven't I I
don't know maybe maybe I have turn
around
I've gone a bit too far at this point
whoo maybe I should turn around there
what was that oh whoa Wow oh god damn it
I was so close
ah [ __ ] oh good it skips bet okay this
may be good it's get past the first part
which means that it's gonna give me
enough time to do that but damn what did
I hit oh god damn it
I think that might have been poop god
i'm hitting everything [ __ ] me it's
ridiculous santen candle that's good
I'll get that
scented candle ah collar Bell works for
me Queen C on a cat collar good enough
matches maybe I need them they're cheap
enough I'll get him and then just a book
get back just a book ebook search alley
with some trepidation you enter some
dark alley as soon as you have entered
the local NER do well threatens you and
demands all your oh I lost half my cash
[ __ ] you god damn it
click still for the book
I think it'll be okay I didn't I luckily
have already spent some of my money soon
I only need the book left and then maybe
repair and maybe fuel but I think I have
enough to get there
we shall see just two more hops to go
yeah I got more than half of you left so
I think we're okay if I don't have a
book in this next town I'm basically
[ __ ] cuz I don't think there's another
turn away until get to the end there so
hopefully please have a book ah perfect
I'll take the Bible this will be great
yes thank you very much I got everything
I needed
I even have matches I have all that [ __ ]
and umm should be good then I should
just be able to make it all the way to
the end and I should be a-ok right right
okay I think so
alright and this time I just got a drive
really carefully like slow as a snail
here we go
oh come on how did I head so I didn't
even see him whoa I didn't even see a
bird geez
oh god dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit that was unavoidable okay
good for you I hope you got a big
appetite I can't swallow all of me
[ __ ] pothole god damn it this is
absurd Oh
what oh god damn it it's another one of
these things yeah this looks like my
computer oh boy I think it told me to
just teabag myself damn it whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm not hitting you
would jeez okay wow that guy really whoa
that guy really wind us more splatter
himself all over my car I think I just
missed a bird - whoa hey buddy [ __ ]
can't Sammy Jesus what the [ __ ] is that
I don't know what that's about
I don't know what that's about super
weird
are you kidding me oh [ __ ] that god damn
it that's such [ __ ] all right so I
was having about a bad luck and I just
ran out of time if you guys can figure
out how to get to the end I'll put a
link to the game in the description
below you can tell me about it and maybe
I'll try to pick it up later but I just
don't have enough time right now so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of this in
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
okay thousand oi
and then boom you're done you're done
you're done yes